hoi iedereen cele Marie kom
vandaag laat ik jullie zien hoe jullie deze lekkere
Kip tasje kunnen maken
met Kip en dijen filet
kijk verder om te zien wat je allemaal nodig hebt
we beginnen met het marineren van de kippendijen filet
alle kruiden die je nodig hebt staan in de omschrijving
als je genoeg tijd hebt
begin dan ruim van tevoren met het marineren hiervan
en leg het dan vervolgens in de koelkast
en als je daar geen tijd voor hebt
dan is dat natuurlijk geen enkel probleem
en dan kan je daar gewoon vlak van tevoren mee beginnen
door om te beginnen wat olijfolie in De Pan
onze traditionele
tagine is helaas te Klein
dus ik HEB gewoon 1 uh ja 1 neppe touching gebruikt
leg de Kip na je filet
in De Pan en dit laat je kort aanbakken
doe dan de UI en de knoflook
erbij en dit laat je ook kort meebakken
vervolgens leg je alle groenten en de aardappelen
ook in De Pan en laat je het vuur gewoon op
de laagste stand staan
ik HEB het gewoon heel de tijd zo gehouden
uh want uh ja
het duurt natuurlijk wel lang voordat de wortelen
gaar worden dus geef het lekker de tijd
en dan top ik het af met wat kruiden
tomaat en koriander
giet er dan wat water bij voor de saus
let wel op dat dit niet boven de groente uit mag komen
top het dan nog wat af met groene olijven
en dan Wil ik jullie heel erg bedanken voor het kijken
en als jullie het ook gaan maken
op zachte kom
geniet ervan en laat mij zeker weten beschermen